when you're designing a speculative
creature where do you like to start
i'll tend to gather
maybe 10 or 20 references that are in
the theme of the direction i'm going
reference images of like fossil life
reconstructions living things even down
to fungi and microscopic creatures and
then i i bring that up in photoshop and
start sketching referencing that
that's alex reese a creature designer
for subnautica below zero and one of the
most talented speculative biology
artists out there many of the creatures
that swim in the seas of planet 4546b
started off as his idea going through
multiple iterations of concept art to
arrive at the awe-inspiring final
designs we see in game
yet there's a lot of incredible art of
unique speculative life forms that for
one reason or another never made it into
the final product
not implementing all designs from early
development stages is a normal part of
pre-production
but some of these designs are so well
thought out they deserve to be studied
further
so for this entry into the archive we'll
explore the incredible unseen creatures
of subnautica examining their potential
biology and how they might fit into the
existing environments of planet 4546b
and if you like the art showcased in
this video you can support alex reese on
patreon using the links below
now let's return to the water of
subnautica and explore the speculative
life forms that could have been
beginning in the vast open regions of
planet four five four six b's ocean some
very unique leviathans almost swam these
enormous curiously shaped creatures are
called thalassians and are imagined to
fill the niche of a peaceful filter
feeder straining small food particles
from the water using specialized mouths
their fin structure gives them a
distinctive profile and alex reese says
the creature uses its rear fins to swim
in a manner similar to the oceanic
sunfish of earth rhys created a lot of
different color variations exploring the
options for pigment and skin texture for
these life forms and i have to say some
of them are really striking like most of
the life forms on this list it's hard
not to wish we could interact with them
in game
other potential organisms are more
deadly one life form that would work
beneath sandy environments is the sand
sphere this terrifying creature is an
ambush predator that buries itself in
sediment and waits for the unwary to
swim overhead before striking in
behavior and appearance the sand spear
somewhat resembles earth's bobbit worm
an alarming looking predator that also
ambushes its prey the sand spears name
and overall lifestyle also recalls the
sand shark from the tropics another
species that buries itself beneath the
sea floor only to emerge in spectacular
fashion to snag its lunch and like the
sand shark the sand spear attacks at
high speeds with the spiky maw extending
out to snap up its prey in addition to
this veritable forest of teeth the head
of the sand spear features two tentacles
that help them sense their targets while
buried these feelers are similar to the
navigational appendages on the front of
certain genera of marine slugs all in
all while sand spears would have been an
exciting inclusion they'd make swimming
near the sea floor much more stressful
upon the ice floats we almost got a very
unusual type of symbiotic organism the
gardener eel is a bizarre creature that
stores a small tree-like plant in its
gullet while on the surface it extrudes
the plant into the waiting sun for
photosynthesis this type of symbiotic
relationship between a plant and animal
can appear in the natural world and can
be seen in the earth leaf sheep a
fascinating type of sea slug i've
mentioned before in other entries leaf
sheep can use the green algae on their
backs to perform photosynthesis and
produce simple sugars for food the
gardener eel doesn't spend all day in
the sun however and can swallow the
membrane and swim like a more
traditional eel when in danger a really
inventive life form
just under the ice of sector zero a
combative predator could have been
prowling this pugnacious creature is a
bulldog trap jaw a midsize lifeform that
doesn't look particularly threatening
while in a neutral position swim too
close however and the trap jaw lives up
to its name by lashing out with a pair
of long raptorial jaws these extendable
mandibles have multiple functions useful
as both an offensive tool and a grasping
mechanism to pull prey into their throat
the various species of morate eels in
earth's oceans have a convergent
adaptation their secondary set of
reptorial jaws are located further back
in the eel's heads and contain their own
set of sharp teeth like the trap jaw
moire eels use their secondary jaws to
restrain prey and drag them deeper into
their gullet ultimately the trap jaw
like the moray eel is a creature you'd
have to be wary of on a dive
deeper into the depths another dangerous
life form could have been waiting in the
eerie light of the crystal caves the
shard runner is a patient hunter
spinning out long fragile mineralized
trip wires to detect prey when an
unlucky soul touches a wire the shard
runner knows their location and strikes
with lethal accuracy this kind of
behavior is almost convergent with that
of certain spiders on land which
likewise can sense any prey that becomes
entangled in the filaments of their web
some spiders can sense their prey using
macroreceptory organs called silts and
cilia so it's likely the shard runner
has developed an analogous sensory organ
to detect life forms entangled in its
own mineralized web
notably some of these hypothetical life
forms are relatives of pre-existing
creatures that evolved to fill different
niches and as a result possess highly
divergent biology one of the most
awe-inspiring creatures from planet
4546b
is the reef back leviathan of the
tropics and these gentle giants almost
had a polar relative in the form of the
icebreaker leviathan a concept which is
one of alex reese's favorites
so if you could add one cut creature you
created into subnautica below zero what
would it be
um i would have gone probably with the
icebreaker leviathan remembering the
reef backs and the impact they had on me
i thought bringing that creature that
design into the arctic environment could
be interesting and one possible take
would be that they have to forge their
way through the ice i knew that would
have a lot of implications when you have
a creature interacting with the
environment like that it could be sort
of a nesting place for the penguins to
live on it could be sort of a moving ice
flow almost uh in the end it wasn't
included i think it just would have been
very very difficult to implement in
terms of programming but i think that
would have been my choice
aside from the reef back out of all the
creatures in the original subnautica one
of the most iconic and most imposing was
the dreaded reaper leviathan for below
zero alex reese imagined that a smaller
yet more agile relative known as the
crested reaper might have terrorized the
frigid waters roughly the size of an
orca the crested reaper are a very
different kind of predator than the
reapers we're familiar with in another
parallel to earth orcas the crested
reaper is exceptionally cunning able to
bump ice flows to knock out of rich prey
into the water a behavior that real
orcas have been observed doing the
crested reaper takes this hunting
strategy a step further however with its
characteristic crest actually a
specialized ice ram that aids in
jostling ice floats the concept of a
smarter more maneuverable offshoot of a
reaper leviathan is really intriguing
albeit slightly scary
other imagined offshoots are far less
menacing as an example we have the grab
squid a smaller more intelligent polar
relative of the huge and terrifying crab
squid much like how the crab squid
possesses a mysterious bioelectric
discharge the tiny grab squid can
generate a weak bioelectric field as a
result the grab squid is naturally drawn
to small electrical devices like
batteries a behavior that mirrors how
its deep water relative is drawn to
larger energy sources large animals
evolving a reduced body size in response
to a limited environment is a
well-documented form of adaptation my
favorite earth example of this are the
channel island mammoths an isolated
population of mammoths that were almost
10 feet or 3 meters shorter than their
mainland relatives so the limited
resources of the frigid sector zero
shaping the massive crab squid into the
tiny grab squid holds up from an
evolutionary perspective curiously an
alternate name for the grab squid
offshoot is the sea monkey as this
concept was actually an early take on
the quite different looking sea monkeys
that made it into the final game
so in your opinion which creature
changed the most during development i
think actually the sea monkey might have
gone through the most iterations because
that thing started off a complete blank
slate it took quite a while to arrive on
a more friendly sort of look because the
focus was more on alienness but we tried
to make it more sort of mischievous and
readable it went in so many strange
directions that one of the creatures
spun off into the tri-valve so the
tri-valve was one of the early sea
monkey attempts but it was so it was
different enough that we managed to spin
it off into its whole other creature
in the vast skies above the teeming
oceans we almost had a unique predator
in the form of the kite wing a relative
of the much smaller sky rays the gentle
sky rays can be seen flying over various
regions of planet 4546b
and are the only life form in either
game to evolve powered flight the
kitewing would add some exciting variety
to the skies of subnautica by being not
just a passive life form but a serious
threat
alex reese imagined a few different
variants of this tyrant of the skies
including one with extra talons and an
imposing crest this head crest resembles
the crown structures of certain
pterosaurs which paleontologists believe
may have emerged for social displays in
improved aerodynamics
so it's likely the mighty crest of the
kite wing serves a similar purpose it's
easy to imagine these swooping terrors
flying through the skies of planet 4546b
returning to entirely unique lifeforms
in the twilight of the abyss a predator
unlike any other could have made an
appearance the ascender worm might
appear like your average squid-like
organism at a glance yet what sets this
life form apart is its highly unusual
hunting method the small ascender wearer
might not have the jaws or muscle to
take down large prey but it has another
weapon
decompression sickness when the ascender
worm hunts it grabs onto its
unsuspecting prey with two deceptively
strong tentacles and rapidly inflates
with gas dragging its target to the
surface in the hopes the pressure change
will kill them decompression sickness
also called the bends is a real danger
that divers face and is caused by
gaseous bubbles forming inside the body
due to depressurization
a grim fate indeed
other theoretical life forms could have
even stranger methods of attack and
defense the shard is a creature that
travels slowly through the water
vertically like a knife luring prey from
below with its glowing lure while this
lure calls to mind the classic angler
fish the shard's vertical swimming
posture actually reminds me of another
deep sea creature the elusive oerfish
which has been recorded swimming in a
similar manner but what really makes the
shard stand out is its defensive
capabilities when attacked it quickly
produces hypersaline slime which rapidly
forms into an ice shell around its body
from which it suddenly swims free this
leaves the predator to attack the
shard's false ice shadow while the real
life form escapes a surreal yet
ingenious form of defense
one of the more distinctive regions of
subnautica below zero is the thermal
spires an ecosystem defined by
chimney-shaped hydrothermal vents one
species which could have been part of
this environment is the vent spider an
arthropod-like animal which would crawl
between the vents on long spindly legs
on earth all kinds of sea spiders have
emerged with some large bottom dwellers
that creep along the sea floor and
others light enough to swim although not
particularly gracefully yet the vent
spider is unique due to its method of
getting food it possesses feathery gills
which gather sulfur from around the
vents to feed extremophile bacteria in
its abdomen strange as this might sound
hydrothermal vents on earth are home to
all manner of specialized life forms
that can feed off the rich chemical soup
the vents produce among these life forms
are bacteria which have evolved to be
highly resistant to the heat of the
boiling vents so the idea of a symbiotic
alliance between such bacteria in a
larger life form like a vent spider
isn't so far-fetched after all
in the original games there's all sorts
of dangerous creatures to look out for
but one particularly unnerving concept
would make these life forms even more
deadly the rot nest is a parasite which
would infect other creatures on planet
4546b this parasite would take over the
brains of their hosts and transform them
into a launching platform for jet
propelled spore pods which would explode
and infect nearby life forms spreading
the infection terrifying as this concept
sounds we can find something similar on
earth one infamous strain of fungus can
take over the bodies of ants hijacking
their minds and essentially turning them
into zombies using their motor functions
to move to an ideal spot to sprout and
spread their spores to other life forms
and the rot nest works in the same way
with their host eventually passing away
in the rottnest slowly digesting what
remains and launching spore pods at any
creatures foolish enough to investigate
a truly menacing concept
get out of all the creatures in
subnautica below zero the shadow
leviathan is perhaps the most
intimidating and well known at multiple
points throughout its development
however it looked quite different i'm
curious what was your process like for
designing the shadow leviathan it came
to a fork in the road with that creature
we needed something big and scary
i did a bunch of initial sketches which
had a more traditional almost like a
dragon like head it had glowing white
teeth and huge jaws like a deep sea
viper fish and stuff like that but sort
of vertebrate looking almost but i also
had a bunch of references of
things called arrow worms horrifying
little invertebrates that just have a
face that's basically a bunch of nested
spines coming out of it i just did one
little study where instead of the
dragon-like face it was this more
invertebrate face among all those that
sort of connected with people a little
bit more it was sort of disturbing and
uh combining that with a bit of lamprey
and a few other marine creatures that
people generally find horrifying uh we
moved in that direction it definitely
scared me during my playthrough
and there's one leviathan which didn't
make it into the final game which might
have been even larger than the shadow
leviathan the ice dragon is a cut
creature with a size and design so
intimidating that it lives up to its
mythical namesake we can see from the
concept art that the ice dragon would
swim on wing-like flippers another
visual nod to the dragons of earth myth
this alien dragon wouldn't breathe fire
however but release a stream of brinycle
ice breath to trap vehicles sort of like
a scaled up version of the brine fish in
the final game which alex reese also
designed in fact the ice dragon is so
large its size could have been an issue
in terms of actually implementing the
life form into the final game while this
is understandable i do wish you could
encounter this frozen terror under the
ice of below zero
and there's one final cut life form we
need to cover all throughout the
original game in its sequel mysterious
structures built by a group of aliens
called precursors or architects remain
abandoned the architects only appear in
game as a.i or artificial
reconstructions so we don't have any
idea what they actually look like or do
we this early concept art by alex reese
shows some potential designs for what
the biological forms of architects could
have looked like the architects are so
mysterious in game i'm curious how you
decided to approach their design i
wanted them to be sort of fastidious
creatures a bit precise nerdy almost so
i tried to design a creature along those
lines something that could use the tools
and the environment that we'd already
seen something that you use a tablet
type computer but still alien so i
started moving in a sort of a direction
that combined amphibious references
reptilian but i think a combination of
salamanders and manta shrimps were my
main inspiration that's so cool
we've now seen an incredible variety of
life forms that almost swam in the
oceans of planet 4546b
and learned a lot about creature design
along the way
a tremendous thank you to alex reese for
being in this episode and sharing
insights into his design process
if you enjoyed discovering the unseen
creatures of subnautica and want to see
more you can support alex reese on
patreon using the links in the
description
and as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry you can lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious
see you in the next video
you